what do you make of the ideas of these
open primaries like they have in New
Hampshire the Republicans spend so much
time whining about the mail in ballots
and like you know what remember that
movie Malice with Alec Baldwin and
Nicole Kidman there's a scene where an
bankr is like get into the game go for
the 20 million yourself that's my
message for the Republicans qu your
whining and do better like if the
Democrats are going to do all this stuff
with the ballot and the harvesting and
all like stop whining just beat them at
their own game if you're not going to
actively work in between elections to
change the laws then exploit them in the
same way the Democrats do